welcome thank you for attending our talk
my name is Aaron house well and I'm at
Bremerhaven
and we both are developers at Echo
Northwest which is an economic
consulting firm based in the Pacific
Northwest that specializes in economics
finance and planning and we work on a
variety of different size projects for
regional and urban planning and
education social policy and economic
impact analysis equi Northwest have been
using Python for about ten years and its
work primarily for larger models and
more recently for data analysis and
visualization just a brief overview of
what we're looking to cover today and
just some background are like our
definitions of kind of how we like to
think about legacy code the planning
process we've gone through a bit testing
git commit for when you're actually
ready to start working on legacy
projects how to upgrade dependencies and
we thought some documentation and then
some closing thoughts okay so when you
hear the term legacy code it tends to be
a fairly loaded term with a lot of
definitions so to that we tend to really
like our one by Michael feathers and he
talks about code without tests so this
is something and it kind of fits in a
little bit with a Scott trig Lea he gave
a great talk at PyCon Canada in 2015
where he described it as code that is
mysterious so we all know the situation
you get brought onto a new project it's
this legacy code thing it's been there
forever you're not quite sure exactly
how it works knowing that there really
knows how it works maybe there's some
mystery around it and then we also like
to think about the idea of software rot
where software rod is really the process
by which code becomes legacy code so
whether you like it or not you're
contributing to software rot almost
everyday so you're hoping hopefully
you're making it better but and
sometimes you're not
the issue isn't really or the question
isn't really about how to stop software
rot software rot is just a process it
happens it's more about how do you
minimize it and how do you reverse it so
some common situations you might run
into are you've inherited a bunch of
code
let's see you the project you're working
with has some monolithic functions or
modules or apps these are ranging from
hundreds to thousands of lines maybe
tens of thousands if you're in a really
bad situation this code has no or a few
tests ideally the few tests that have
are good if they're bad then you're in
it then they might as well not exist you
have some outdated dependencies this is
often a common case using an old version
of Django for example or pandas or
something along those lines and then as
well you have minimum or out-of-date
documentation again on updates almost
being worse than none so we had a couple
projects over the last few years but we
approached in different ways but the
first thing we thought about for both of
them was kind of if you were to design
this project from scratch and you were
in a Greenfield State what would you
think about and how would you approach
it what are different ways to approach
it and essentially we like to kind of
take a step back and prototype and this
can be varying degrees of kind of you
know think about it like a paper outline
varying different varying degrees of
detail but what we found was that in one
case we did a prototype and it actually
wasn't going to be that much more work
to get it to a viable product in terms
of so essentially we ended up doing a
complete rewrite and this is a really
rare case but it was kind of an
interesting case because it was code
that we were the only users of wasn't in
current production and there was a lot
of a lot of features that were no longer
needed and so this first prototyping
stage kind of helped us for both of
these projects determine which approach
to take
and this one actually with the complete
rewrite it ended up working out really
well for us which is again a rare case
you're not you're usually going to be
doing an incremental approach so usually
that's that's the approach you'll take
and that's and that was a case where the
code was in production
lots of end users we really needed to be
careful about how how we made our
changes and really that the key thing
that we did was separating the
refactoring from any bug fixes and we'll
talk a little bit more about that in our
git commit section but still the first
step of prototyping was really helpful
because you kind of have this goal in
terms of what you think the code could
like look like in the back of your mind
throughout the process and it was really
cool to see that a year after we started
the kind of refactoring and redesign
process the code actually looks a lot
like our prototype with some
improvements so testing so you've gone
through you've planned a little bit you
have a vague idea of how you want to get
started and now you're going to do what
everyone tells you you should do testing
and the thing you have to realize right
away is that you can't test everything
at once especially if you're starting
from a place where you have minimal or
no testing you have an entire you have
an entire code basically you could start
with you have to decide and determine
what you're going to get the most bang
for your buck out of one of the areas of
the code that are most important and
typically when we want to about this
approach we started with high level
tests so more functional tests for us we
really needed to make sure that for our
model it produced the same output after
we made changes as it did before so we
were able to do is we were able to build
essentially a suite of comparison tests
so what this would do is we had a lot of
user data already for inputs for our
model and what we were able to do is we
would run the model with our initial
tests we would you know check out our
new code we would make some changes and
then
would compare the outputs and see what
had changed where did the changes make
sense were there no changes if there was
a change with this regression we're we
fixing a bug what were we doing building
this kind of test apparatus while not
being you know pure unit tests gave us a
tremendous amount of confidence and I
think that's really one of the best or
one of the biggest benefits of testing
especially when working with legacy
systems is being confident that when you
change something you're not going to
break the world it's going to be all
right and while we could have we might
have been missing some cuffs cases and
some other things along those lines we
felt that the trade-off was well worth
it choosing what to test really is all
about risk management are you willing to
take the risk that introducing of
introducing your regression if it means
getting to a better place quicker so
other things I was especially very
guilty of was I would get in I'd say all
right it must be time to write unit
tests now I would write an entire suite
of unit tests for a section of code and
then we would just go about and
completely rewrite that section of code
to the point where the initial unit test
I wrote were useless so one thing to
keep in mind is avoid writing tests that
might soon be discarded focus on writing
unit tests for code that is either
state-like going to be stable or that is
approaching a stable state otherwise
you're kind of just wasting your time
and this one was huge for us so testing
tended to be a newer part of our
workflow is there an I mentioned we're
an economic consulting firm not a
traditional software development
background but one thing to kind of
build this into our development culture
was to automate this into the workflow
so we use git lab it's a self service
get other people who use github and what
it has this nice pipelines feature which
allows you to every time you either push
code or create a merger pull request
you're able to run your test suite so we
were able to run our you comparison
testing we were able to run the unit
test we were starting to build we were
able to
check our to make sure that we weren't
having regressions in terms of style
that we weren't introducing paid
violations and whatnot and this I found
to be very helpful in terms of pushing
off the nitpicking onto a system rather
than a person when you're working you
never want to be the person to say well
actually you have to your line links are
a little too long or oh this doesn't
quite match Pepe and those things I tend
to find important and we'll get to this
in a little bit in terms of how much
readability matters it was in our case
and being able to push this off on to
someone else or on to something else was
very helpful so now you're thinking you
might start refactoring what were the
first things we thought about the first
couple of things we we really thought
about were what is one of our big
concerns just given kind of the the type
of projects we were working on and
system was readability we were finding
that we were having really long
onboarding times because it was a
combination of getting into you know
complicated code base so then also
learning the subject matter behind it
and so readability was a big concern for
us and so we kind of we focused on two
things Pepe and flight gate had Auto
linting and really the you know you're
not actually changing any code hopefully
but really unifying the style and
getting rid of all those violations and
based on your your internal style guide
or the style guide you follow and then
improving readability with minimal risk
so these are things like just adding
more comments
so the pepe process and improving
readability just through Pepe or your
style guideline really you'll find a lot
of things during that process and it's
really tempting to make the bug fix
there but instead we would just do a
comment so it depend on the type of
issue we would do an issue in good lab
and then also using kind of these
special special phrases note bug fix me
to do review the other thing that we
really but I think was one of the
biggest things that we did was when you
have thousand line functions is just
taking the minimum number of steps you
can to break it into new functions and
new new files even so really very
minimal changes but just that separation
allows you to get to a better place to
do integration tests and functional
tests and unit tests and then also avoid
premature refactoring so like what when
you're I mean you're actually gonna
start making structural changes to the
code and implementing new design and
what is the value add that you're adding
and one guiding priority for us was
again readability so you know if the
refactoring you're doing isn't going to
enhance that then think it through a bit
more and one thing I found myself doing
is when you're reading a code base you
you have your own style of coding and
you you have your you have your biases
or things in the code that you're
reading that are particularly like not
maybe your style and so you have bias
views based on the code that you're
working in and to really be aware of
them and not swing in the opposite
direction and introduce new issues based
on trying to solve current issues in the
code so just and again this is where
kind of the prototyping stage helped us
a bit which was to always kind of take
that stuff back and get get out of some
of it sometimes the current code you're
working in and get a fresh perspective
and again this this was for our firm the
right and for these projects was the
focus we had look and with readability
but that'll be different based on your
needs but really be be aware of your
objectives and you know we sacrifice
some speed and kind of elevate not
elegance but swiftness I guess for lack
of a better word on inter in favour of
readability but as we'll talk a little
bit in documentation and you know we
making documenting those style choices
and what you're you're knowingly
p-nut trade-off for is important so
you've started making changes to your
code and whatnot and you realized you
have a bunch of dependencies that you
need to get up-to-date these aren't
necessarily related to your project
there's someone else's project and you
need to get up to date so a few pieces
of advice this may be obvious to some
people it took me a little bit to learn
so Python when you're running Python
there's a dash W flag and that allows
you to bring up deprecation warnings I
found this to be incredibly helpful
pretty much a go-to not only when it
comes to refactoring but just working
with Python in general so what this will
do is if your package has any
deprecation warnings again as I had
mentioned we use Django and Django is
very good about their deprecation
warnings it's one of my favorite aspects
of the package this allows you to see
what is going to break in future
versions before you hit it so while this
may add a little bit of extra work ahead
of time in terms of making changes it
saves you a lot of time later on and it
kind of gives you an idea of where is
the length or where is this package
going what kind of things can I expect
to change in the future on top of that
one thing I recommend is just try
upgrading everything at once and see
what happens if you love the project
that doesn't have a particularly complex
or particularly high number of
dependencies or is relatively simple
this may work for you and this worked
for a number of our projects it was
using Django but it wasn't using
anything too fancy or too crazy using
just the pulling up deprecation warnings
we had to make a couple tweaks but that
was it that's all we had to do we went
straight from 1-4 to 111 and that's all
we needed so I highly recommend giving
that a chance while it may be a little
riskier it's definitely worth it and
will save you a lot of time if that's
something you can do however that's
probably not going to be the case
depending on your project especially if
it has a lot of dependencies have a lot
of complexity built in you're probably
going to have to build some kind of
upgrade plan or as opposed to getting
from A to B you may have to make some
stops along the way so one thing I
recommend you do if you have a bunch of
complex crazy dependencies is
if you if there is a central dependency
build your plan around that so for us
ours was Jango and we were starting
around jingo 1-4 and we were trying to
get up to a later version of Jango so
how we built it is we set up minor steps
along the way so we would try to upgrade
to the latest version of jingle 1:5 then
jingle 1:6 then jingle 1:7 and for each
of those we would find out for all of
our other packages what's the last
version that would support that one so
it's brought a couple of benefits one it
added some sanity to the process and in
addition it gave us the ability to it
gave us the ability to deploy as we are
going so as opposed to one thing to
definitely worry about is saying oh I'm
going to refactor my codebase and I'll
be back in six months while I do this
and then all of a sudden we will
integrate all of our changes one of the
best things we were able to do is
integrating that refactoring via the
iteration process being able to deploy
code as quickly as often as possible by
breaking this into smaller steps we were
able to do that unfortunately well in an
ideal world
each of these dependencies would
explicitly mention which versions of
Jango they're compatible with for
example or whatever your central project
is unfortunately that is not also always
the case and you might have to do some
dependency sleuthing to be able to
figure it out a few places that I found
were really helpful with this is one and
probably most obviously the changelog
usually if your project has a change log
it will include information about when
it drops dependency for certain versions
that was helpful for other projects
though that wasn't the case and I was
able to looking through the tox files or
the Travis CI files if they have those
that'll tell you exactly which versions
of let's say Jango or another thing
they're looking through or they're
testing against and once they drop for
example let's say once they drop one
five you know that the previous version
before that is the last version that
supports hopefully so that was able to
doing that was able to help and then in
addition to all this if you still are
really confused about the package
I highly recommend just reaching out to
the author and especially if it's a
smaller project and just asking saying
hey I'm trying to upgrade this project
I'm trying to get my code to a better
place would you be able to help me out a
little bit and as long as you're not
asking for too much usually they're more
than happy to and if it's not explicit
where things drop they'll probably say
hey I'll help you just be sure to do a
pull request and add this information
for others in the future and so one of
one of the things when you have legacy
projects as you have documentation
perhaps and maybe it's and maybe it's up
to date maybe it's not and one one
question that I often would get asked
was well if you get hit by a bus
tomorrow
what's going to happen and I like to
think that tech free vacation and but
it's the same idea and not really
focuses you on thinking like what is
what is mission-critical and what is my
wishlist of documentation that I think
would be really helpful for my team to
have but you know it's not going to it's
potentially things they could google and
find a you know an answer online
workflow and/or other sources but really
what is mission-critical
so really basic things deployments
overview of the architecture of the
project how things work and then what
happens if something goes wrong like if
your ec2 instance goes down and you
don't have documentation on how to get
that back up so and then the other thing
that I think in particular when you are
working with legacy code is you don't
want to have the end of your refactor
process and redevelopment process and
with another legacy code base because
you you have a team that is that you're
that maybe you're the most experienced
person on the team and things that seem
obvious to you are not obvious to
newcomers to the codebase and so writing
down your vision and identifying the
limitations of your design and
things you'd like to do but maybe just
aren't the right design choice at the
moment and will help your future self
and your coworkers and I think in
particular with data analysis projects
writing down what you tried and hit
roadblocks with and having not
documented not just in your your mind is
really important sometimes what you did
it what you tried to do but isn't what's
actually in the code is just as
important as what is what's there and
then testing your documentation because
the kind of this goes back to if you
have a team that's the people that are
most experienced with the codebase and
they write all the documentation I think
it looks great but it really is not
useful to somebody that's just worrying
about the project and so what we did is
really tried to have a development team
that had people that were you know
really experiencing the code bases and
people that were this was just their
first introduction and really
encouraging them to be ask questions and
like question like if they hear you
talking about something that they don't
understand or that isn't obvious to them
asking you and then documenting it and I
think another kind of clothing thought
of in particular risks economic
consulting and our experiences that
we're you know this we're you know we're
an economic consulting firm with a lot
of social science scientists and we're
becoming we're getting more and more
into software development and using data
analysis and data visualization and
Python primarily for our work and you
have to be aware of a lot of these
legacy projects as context in terms of
what did they start out in in some cases
you might be working on the first
iteration of the code in Python and
before it was in Excel and so just that
transition from Excel to Python or from
Stata or MATLAB is it really can be a
really big improvement based on the code
base so really be aware of that and be
appreciative of kind of what the history
might have looked like it's really easy
to think why is why aren't there why
isn't there better better testing but if
you're really moving from something with
no good version control system to Python
let's get in the get lab or github or
whatever your preferences that in and of
itself is a really big improvement and
then also just understanding that you
you read a lot about Bres best practices
and it's really important to understand
what they are and understand kind of
where you currently fall where you'd
like to fall and what what you're what
what's important for your your work and
customizing it a bit not just you know
take assuming that whatever's out there
is going to fit your needs for your
company and a couple of really important
talks that we that we found helpful was
was one by Ben Lopez from Django Khan in
2016 on working working with legacy
django apps and then also scott trig lea
which is working effectively with legacy
code from PyCon 2015 and they go through
some good examples and code
and we are happy to take any questions
you might have
hi so one of your points was avoid
writing tests and may soon be discarded
and only do it for code that is stable
or soon to be in a stable state and the
kind of sounds like a contradiction of
what you know to be the core values of
TDD so I was wondering can you give me a
specific example so that I can better
understand when you would want to apply
this idea yeah so I think what what we
meant by that is when you have like
thousands of lying functions you really
want to focus on you know that it's it's
really difficult to even get that jump
like a unit size and so we still
implement a test-driven development and
writing the test before the code but we
we try to if it was if we were really
making just kind of making things into
chunks and not actually making any real
changes to logic but just breaking it
into smaller pieces and we didn't start
we wrote functional text or integration
test for that and then when we knew we
were in a position to actually write and
get it down at the unit level then we
started doing the test-driven
development with unit tests is that help
so an example I can kind of think of and
it's hard to describe the exact details
of it but a situation that we would run
into is we would have let's say you know
a given function or a given weight so
one example that we were using with this
is we would be like representing a like
a social welfare policy for example and
like how one would calculate that and we
would have a certain way that we would
do it
let's say that was way a and we knew
that at some point we wanted to get to
wayy like this is the way that we're
going to do it and we're going to get
there within three months but there's
several ways there were a few ways in
which we essentially we were trying to
transition to that and we knew that it
was going to each of those subsequent
you know B C and D we're going to live
for such a small period of time that to
write extensive testing and all that
just wasn't it wasn't going to be worth
it it wasn't going to be worth the the
investment in it it was better to get
get to eat quicker and then write your
extensive test than it is and yeah I
guess that is kind of a break between
TDD but I'm not I'm not too worked up it
doesn't it
I still got sleep over it yeah I think
yeah it depends on and kind of what
you're you're testing I or what your
code looks like in terms of how you
approach testing I think and work for us
pretty well
if I'd like to make a comment actually
on that last point you never have an
infinite amount of money for testing so
exactly what you said it's bang for the
buck so a good way of thinking about is
expected value there's a the chance that
something's going to go wrong versus the
cost of that particular thing sometimes
called blast radius and so if you're
doing what you've just described code
motion the chance of something going
wrong is very low on the other hand if
it's your core algorithm you might want
to put a tester on it yeah but so
testing is always bang for the buck you
know your customers have been testing
your legacy code for the last ten years
a chance of there being bug in that is
pretty low the chance of the de new code
is quite high because development
produces two things which is code and
bugs correct and so you know that you
it's the new changes but anyway my
question is that's a great list because
they agree with it all but what were
some things that you thought would be
useful when you went into this and some
practices that you thought would be the
right way to go and you actually found
were not along the way one of the big
ones I think was we thought that so we
have worked on an initial project and
that's where we had done the complete
rewrite so this was a model that had you
know a core central economic theory
behind it which we were kind of able to
pluck out and put into a new spot and
then we moved on to a more complex
project and initially thought oh we can
just do the same thing right and we
worked on that for a few months and then
we kind of you know started trying to do
the core of the terrible parallel
development and then after a while we
kind of realized this we have to tailor
our approaches to two different things
so that I guess that was a really good
example of yeah we had this one one
project where we had you know we had
millions and tons and tons of data from
the model so we were able to I mean it
was able to cover pretty much this
pretty much the span of solution sets
and you know and that approach there was
a lot of other features but they're no
longer needed in the codebase and it was
that was adding a lot of weight and so
it actually was a lot easier to bring
the kind of court rewrite kind of sort
course we'll bring out and then kind of
reorganize the course theory of the
model its but then you had this just
expansive testing database so you could
really do a lot of i/o testing in terms
of how your new model was performing and
that's kind of where that we the
prototyping phase we kind of approached
the second project similar to that and
again you know is pretty pretty clear
early on that we thought wasn't the
right route that was in production it
was a very different case but that
prototyping was still really helpful in
terms of taking a step back and how you
would like the model to work and how you
would like the pieces to work together
because oftentimes it's very different
than how it is currently and it was you
know it was designed for application X
and now you're doing X Y Z and you want
it to just work differently any other
questions I found with a lot of those
sorry suggestions it requires a lot of
personal discipline from the members of
your team so I assume you have some kind
of sense of ownership for your
repositories somebody can you move some
like a little bit closer it's hard for
us as editor yes should I start over
uh maybe okay so a lot of what y'all are
talking about requires personal
discipline throughout the team and so I
assume you have some kind of some kind
of a responsibility on the repo that
belong to somebody that maintains code
hygiene that looks at things and says
your pet bait but this is not pythonic
things like that I was wondering what
your approach is to sort of enforcing
that kind of that kind of discipline
throughout your team too so that you're
not writing legacy code as you're
removing and well I think Indian in
terms of this style the pup 8 we had
that
so whenever somebody would push the
origin it would run linting on their
code and if that failed if it failed
them you know you can customize it a bit
it's your own style but that was kind of
one way to enforce style but then it was
also a small team so it's not a team of
you know 100 devs or you know it was a
small group of people so you have kind
of different management needs in terms
of based on size and size
yeah yeah we definitely benefited from
having a team that all was fairly on the
same page like there we didn't really
have anyone on our team that's like Pepe
what's that that's just something we're
in a random person came up with like
that was an issue we ran into everyone
was kind of on the same page in terms of
like this is what this is what we want
this is what's right we want to go with
this and especially when it came to like
Aaron had mentioned kind of pushing that
off onto in our case get lab but for
github it would be like Travis CI it it
makes it so you agreed to the rules and
you make it so people can't everyone
everyone's agreed to it ahead of time so
no one can really break it and if
someone does break it it's not like I'm
attacking them or like I'm going after
them
for breaking it it's this robot over
here this machine over here is telling
them that and I found that to be kind of
helpful and it yeah it was definitely
culture like being able to build it up
into the culture really helped kind of
get everyone on the same page
I wondered when you're working with a
customer do you really work with them to
factor the cost of long-term support of
both the app but also all the components
underneath the app that the app is
relying on is that an easy conversation
with a customer do they get it that's a
good question um you know I think you
you have to with some of the legacy
projects you have maintenance contracts
in place and when they were started and
so you kind of you have to work within
those constraints and sometimes what we
found is that sometimes even within the
given maintenance contract it's worth it
to to do some work so that you can fix
bugs faster and that's going to save you
a lot of time in the long run and so
that's kind of been the approach when
you know if you if things don't quite
meet your needs are there steps you can
take to refactor your code base so that
you're not getting issues from the
customers and why it's why am I getting
these results and to being able to do a
lot quicker bug development but moving
forward it varies by customer and what
they what they care about I mean there's
a phrase in consulting which is good
cheap quick pick two and so you kind of
have to think within those lines in
terms of what they what their what their
issue what their concerns are
it would tempt them I mean maybe we're
just lucky we have some pretty fantastic
clients who kind of understood they we
were able to explain to them but you
know the situation that we were in and
how
taking this time now and you know
investing this money and being able to
get it what the repr like what the what
they would be able to benefit out of it
and they were able to see that and yeah
typically it's we have I like to assume
that people are you know rational and
nice and understand things at first
until they don't and we never had to get
to the and in case they don't part they
were all very good
if there are no more questions we can
wrap up the session
thank you Matt and Aaron and I'm sure
they'll be available for questions after
and then lightning talks begin at 4:00
in McKinley so the big room down there
where the keynotes are thank you I do
[Applause]